[Music]
hello there it's been a while how the
heck are you if you're new around these
parts this is the series totally
dedicated to the map changes we see each
week on fortnite island it's been a
little dry this season but with the
halloween update only one week away we
have a few sub stories to check out and
i'll also recap what's happened over the
past fortnight in fortnite so sit your
butt down for five minutes and please
think about using code adamaru to join
the list of legends at the end of each
episode
and let's break down the latest update
[Music]
last update our focus shifted to the
gnomes of fortnite as we saw two key
events happening the genomes that
survived holly hatchery were moving out
their bags were packed they were ready
to go and on the opposite side of the
island the gnomes rounded up by the
sheriff in the jail cell were broken out
thanks to a daring high explosive escape
then they vanished straight up gone but
thanks to your help we found every
single gnome that's almost 40 of them
attempting to leave the island first the
prison break the hole in the wall shows
their exit plans and every single one of
them has gone none in sight follow the
valley down to the south and you will
see one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fifteen sixty seventeen eighteen
eighteen a literal army of gnomes have
made a mad dash south and are climbing
into a set of kayaks there's even a cool
gandalf style gnome lifting a light
showing the way to go fearless as ever i
was unable to find the buckethead guy
from last week which is a shame that guy
could have been an icon for us all i
would have bought that skin elsewhere
the missing gnomes from holly were found
at the water's edge near the viking ship
once again jumping into a boat to sail
away where the heck could they be going
remember the cool laying down gnome from
the bench well he's still here and he's
still laying down he's as cool as ever i
was hoping they'd all make it to hot
watch but that's very unlikely now as
they're all traveling off at different
angles especially when you see the third
troop
i totally missed these guys last update
up at craggy cliffs but come on how much
does this hit you in the fields i feel
like we should have some different music
now to make it cry
it became apparent they were looking at
the boats and to my surprise it wasn't
the beached vessel in the distance it's
yet another kayak the three gnomes are
now there on the shoreline putting their
teeny tiny luggage on board and on the
cliff edge those two elders continue to
watch as their comrades leave the island
does that mean these two are staying if
they're seeing them off from this angle
who knew we could care about inanimate
objects like this another bromance has
blossomed by the way this guy is a
little different from the rest he has a
book i don't know if that's important
but i feel it's worth a mention i'll
keep an eye on it for you because
honestly i have nothing better to do
with my time there is another set of
gnomes leaving the island but these guys
ain't a fan of water
gnomes at retail row decided to wait for
the bus to get out either way they are
leaving retail row just before the
halloween update hits
[Music]
so have you been keeping an eye on the
old skull villain base the grotto this
season a year or two ago this was a top
drop spot for many players but since
then it was closed and fell into
disrepair we couldn't get inside
suddenly this season something started
to happen the water levels began to fall
was this a coincidence or was something
happening here then this week it
happened again only a tiny change i mean
minuscule the muck underwater is now on
top of the water line that's literally
it just that tiny bit it does make you
think though something is definitely
happening here with halloween on the way
what is more iconic than a skull maybe
this could be the home for shadow
minions or even midas himself i did a
little research and the only other skull
shaped location we've seen this chapter
is from the day aurelia was revealed a
piece of law showed us marigold finding
her tomb and that place looked a great
deal like the grotto could this be the
time to see it revealed in game man i
hope so but let's hold our horses for a
moment it's only a tiny change in water
level it could mean nothing at all
it wouldn't be a map update video
without the legend that is the tiny
chair have you visited this thing this
week
this time around it has grown again the
bear and the chair and the telescope
have marginally grown and are now on par
with the size of a chest nothing
spectacular but the legend continues to
grow next update should see the chair
grow to its original size
and i'm still hoping it won't stop there
we need a hugely oversized bear on a
hugely oversized chair next to a hugely
oversized telescope whichever fortnight
dev made this you're awesome thank you
very much
and the final update this week is all
about sloan and her motley crew this
week they are about to enter retail row
still carrying the same load on an io
truck and still flanked by the same two
aisle vehicles
five weeks ago now we saw them claiming
debris from the fallen mothership damn
five weeks already time flies later that
week they took this path moving towards
the hot watch farm across the bridge
past the collapsed io base over the next
bridge to this crossroads at retail row
a theory the community is hoping that
comes true is sloan is going to open the
bunker the redacted bunker we've been
watching for years and thanks to that
turn towards retail it's now totally
possible this is the distance to the
bunker it's about three or four updates
away which would make it about october
26th they got here unbelievably close to
halloween and only two days before the
secret skin for the season is revealed
what do you think will happen is this
another bait and switch or will we
finally see inside the redacted bunker
and to confirm that this is important
when sloane and her gang got to this
crossing the cube was scheduled to go
over the road and crush it but instead
it deliberately went round that vehicle
whatever sloan is doing it's important
to the storyline so the other thing
about map changes in the last month is
that they're constantly happening thanks
to the cubes rolling around i've done my
fair share of watching and waiting and
sometimes the cubes do nothing at all
and i've wasted my time which is truly
heartbreaking but each roll brings us
closer to the end game i'm sure you've
noticed how each tumble of the cubes
creates a corruption trail right now
these are spiraling towards the center
point of the island in fact as i'm
saying this the golden cube is a matter
of hours away from its final resting
place so keep an eye on it today and
tomorrow in case you missed it over the
last two weeks the golden cube made it
to all the remaining purple cubes and
awoke them floating in the air firing
out an energy beam which somehow forces
the cube to come alive and have babies
biology isn't my strong point but that's
how babies are made if anyone asks the
thing to know is that all the purple
cubes have offspring except for one of
them the one from steamy stacks the one
we believe to be kevin the cube from
chapter one he even gives us a hint at
this by leaving kev out in the far court
of steamy stacks before rolling away
this cube doesn't act completely like
the others at one point it deliberately
finds a high spot on the island to have
a look around and stayed there for about
a day for no reason at all this cube is
unlike the others and this kevin doesn't
want to have kids it's his choice i
guess oh and a random thing happened to
me getting this shot i usually move
vehicles and builds out of the way to
make things like this look better and
here i move this truck can you guess
where it ends up let's see it finds a
llama i have no idea why i'm showing you
this i hope you enjoyed over the next
week many things will start happening
halloween decor will begin to arrive on
the island as people start feeling
spooky the superstar should see its
annual update to becoming the home of
horror and then in two weeks everything
becomes clear oh and if you're wondering
the blue cube still hasn't moved at all
lazy lazy bugger okay on screen now and
a bunch of code adamara legends who are
kind enough to use my code this season
thank you so much for choosing my code
it makes a massive difference to my life
i took a break from youtube and twitter
dms over the last few weeks but i'm
ready to come back make content and
start replying again so thank you and
sorry if i haven't replied to you just
yet know that you're awesome and i
appreciate you i'm adam i'll see you
next time
[Music]
bye